[Music]
we all know Disney has a lot of Secrets
and makes a lot of changes many of us
don't really agree with well they also
made some changes in the dissonance too
that would affect the entire movie as
well as descendants three
wait until you see which minor character
had a chance to say one of the most
important lines give this video a thumbs
up if you love descendants and don't
forget to subscribe to our Channel
now let's check out some of the deleted
scenes from dissonance 2 that changed
everything
dump Cameron sings if only let's start
off with dub Cameron's deleted scene
that would have been everyone's favorite
but for some unexplainable reason Disney
decided to cut it out of the second
movie even though it's most likely that
the song would be pretty popular hands
up if if only was your favorite song
from the first movie
it was definitely ours which is why we
think it's a shame this scene got
completely deleted from descendants 2 it
starts off with mal and Jay sharing a
cute moment and then mal breaks out Anna
if only reprise you can watch the entire
scene on the descendants to DVD it still
breaks our heart when we find out that
they decided to delete this scene from
the original movie and we're demanding
to know why we bet it'd be one of the
cutest scenes yet speaking of dub
Cameron did you know that there's a
scene in the movie that almost got cut
because of her chemistry with Thomas
Doherty do you remember when Harry ran
his hook through mouths hair even though
the moment wasn't really a big deal for
the two characters you could feel the
chemistry between the two actors and
it's exactly why the team wanted to
delete the scene if you had to choose
which one would you go for the Harry and
mal scene or having another glimpse of
if only we'd prefer the scene with if
only although we'd quite like to see the
romance between Harry and mal blossom
but this particular part is not the only
romantic scene Disney decided to totally
cut out from the movie without giving an
official reason for it the kissing scene
if you're a true descendents fan you've
probably heard of this before
it's the viral picture that made every
single fan excited for the second movie
of course we have to also talk about the
kissing scene that becomes huge news for
all descendants fans it's the kissing
scene between Harry and Gil and first
reason we've never seen it on the
dissonance - but we have seen it on
Thomas Dougherty's Instagram he
captioned it asking what will you tell
your kids you did on July 1st the date
of the dissonance - premiere and then he
added this strange sentence he doesn't
say who it's about but the sentence
reads a truly inspiring the beautiful
human being is he talking about Dylan
Playfair fans had a lot to say about
this spoiler and many were left
disappointed after no such scene
actually appeared in dissonance - there
were of course many rumors but nobody
knows the reason why this scene never
happened we're Dylan and Thomas just
messing on sat or is there more to this
picture this deleted scene truly would
have changed everything including the
history of Disney's lack of LGBT
characters a Disney Channel spokesperson
issued a statement that this depiction
is not in the movie and was not scripted
or directed as it was an improvised
moment by actors on the set what do you
think both actors posted the same photo
on their own accounts and it soon went
viral was it really just a casual moment
between the two if so when this team
then appear in the dissonance - bloopers
it's one of the most talked about
moments of the movie and according to
Disney it didn't even happen but at
least the actors reach their goal and
made absolutely everyone talk about the
movie this scene with Harry the
descendants is known for leaving us with
a cliffhanger that indicates the story
will continue in the first movie the
final line belongs to mal you didn't
think this was the end of the story did
you her eyes turn green as she turns
away from Ben and
miles at the camera in the second movie
the last line belongs to Allah who makes
it seem that the third movie will be
incredible dark and mysterious but it
turns out that the last line was
practiced on several people including
Harry IV seen it Harry walks on the book
whistling the tune of you and me becomes
closer to the camera and asks the exact
same question as umma and now then he
strokes his chin with his hook as darker
music comes on gives an evil laugh and
slowly backs away and out of the shot we
have to say that Harry's was definitely
our favorite and the most mysterious
take why do you think they decided to
delete the scene and went with umma
instead speaking of Harry and mal did
you know that the cast decided that
Harry is mouths first love right on the
spot it wasn't originally meant to be in
the script but after seeing the weird
tension between them they decided to
give it a meaning we're pretty sure
using Harry in the ending scene would
change everything but not introducing
Harry and mouths relationship would also
leave fans wondering why they are hating
each other in the first place this scene
with dizzy Jermaine but Harry wasn't the
only one who's seen Disney decided to
leave out they also deleted the
potential scene with the same lines
using dizzy to remain dizzy is the
youngest character in The Descendants
franchise but many fans loved her sweet
and innocent look in the second movie
she's cute and adorable even though
she's officially the daughter of
Drizella Jermaine one of Cinderella's
stepsisters just like Harry did he had a
moment that could have appeared in the
movie in the deleted scene she gets
handed a parchment which was an
invitation personally delivered by then
to attend auradon prep this scene also
appears in the actual movie but what
happened next was completely deleted she
excitedly turns around and runs away
from the camera then she stops turns
back and comes back over she looks
directly into the camera and says the
famous dissonance line you didn't think
this was the end of the story did you
she gives him his TV a smile looks at
the parchment
giggles and runs
way with dizzy saying the final line it
could mean that she would appear again
in the third movie and perhaps her good
girl character will become more
developed in descendants three as of
November 2017
there has been no confirmation that Anna
Cathcart will appear on the dissonance
three cast list but we have a feeling
Disney definitely considered it with
that deleted scene what do you think are
you a fan of dizzy make sure to let us
know your own predictions for new
synonyms three and two would you like to
see on the cast list that's it for our
video if you'd like to see more of
descendants make sure to watch ten
rumors about descendants 3 you need to
hear see you next time
[Music]